[Music]
we formed adult men's club a while back
we got tired of reading and hearing so
much about people always trying to get a
fancier car a bigger house travel to
more exotic places and come home and
tell everybody they go to Las Vegas and
go back said hey I heard a hurt Neil
Diamond
you know big deal dull men's club is the
place in cyberspace where dull men can
hang out and share their experiences
with fellow dull man and women that
appreciate though man it's a sanctuary
for a place they can hide out get away
from the glitz and glam the hurly-burly
all the noise of modern life the
pressures to keep up with the Joneses I
don't know who the Joneses are anyway
you we regard ourselves as dull but not
boring we're grateful for so many things
in their lives
there's the biskits appreciation society
the traffic cone Preservation Society
the apostrophe protection Society the
cloud appreciation society it goes on
and on
[Music]
the minutes are rolled up to this round
of eggs
I was tingling all over at the beauty of
it this whole setting just just greet
sherds it's so quintessentially English
in its appearance
it's a listing duckpond actually on a
roundabout I've travelled from John
O'Groats to Land's End and I've never
seen a duck pond on a round available I
thought I'd seen everything but this is
certainly going to grace the front cover
of our calendar for 2014 oh the years
I've seen some darn good brand about
some people go for a picturesque
roundabouts like the one I'm sitting on
we call those tits marshes which is an
island in full bloom but other people
the functionalist in our society they
might go for the Magic Roundabout in
Swindon which is the white-knuckle ride
of all roundabouts it's a real Malstrom
of motor them our society go on day
trips there and spend the day just going
round around there's the Dorking
cockerel there's the bath Regency round
of Ed you could almost see the crack of
leather a widow with that round of it's
beautiful I'd like to see a round about
as an oasis on a sea of tarmac I think
they lift our sagging spirits on long
tiresome journeys then that light
robotic fascist traffic lights how many
times have you been on a set of traffic
lights oh there's nothing coming but
you're just standing there burning off
petrol roundabouts are far more green
and traffic lights which has to be
maintained after whereas to maintain and
renovate so you just got a mogul or now
a breather
[Music]
we find there's a lot of joy and just
sitting on a park bench for example like
here in this beautiful park and right in
the middle of London to take my time
time is what keeps everything from
happening all at once but you know
Cleveland Square is not really a square
it's actually a trapezoid a lot of the
squares in London are not squares Sloane
Square is a rectangle Grosvenor Square
is not a square it's an oval I think
there really should be a renaming of
these squares in London we have adult
man of the year listing every year and
one of the nominees last year was
retired postman living in Malvern and
Worcestershire wonderful box absolutely
love it 160 years old but a rubbish
plate and when it was put on it was put
on crooked I like this spot enjoy it
very quiet you got two boxes for the
price of one the hobby has become a
photographic challenge not only I could
ever photo up them all there are 115,000
table give of boxes in Roma's collection
I think I've probably done about two and
a half thousand it's become addictive in
a way that it takes me to places that I
would not normally visit and one of my
dear wife's interest is following a
musical show around the country and
we've actually seen it over 80 times now
in 40 different theaters and we've taken
many many hotels and one of the
advantage of that is of course in very
there is a post box near the hotel and
they come in all shapes and sizes in
Stoke some years ago three boxes right
now inside the front door present
one of the benefits of joining to the
letterbox study group is access and use
of their database and with the help of
my son I have been able to get those
references into my GPS unit and we've
set it that it will give me an alarm a
little ding-a-ling warning when I
approach a postbox
I never leave them or rarely leave home
without it they were trying to hunt out
the gray days and the gray piece and try
and find them one can go walking around
the side streets in towns and villages
and you meet different people new people
their curse as to what one is doing
sometimes one can get some hooks and
laughs and passing vehicles
[Music]
one of our members has a collection of
Airport sickness bags another member
collects toothpicks
another member collects restaurant menus
we have over a hundred categories of
items now that there are museums for
like soap coat hangers typewriters
staplers shopping trolley like all
collecting you go to the dealers you've
got the people who collect from monetary
advancement but there are quite a few of
us who are quite dedicated mobile
collectors who collect them for their
own sake I mean technically seventeen a
half thousand nutballs and not worth
anything
they're just glass the most common thing
on the planet but to me they're worth
millions groose in my pride and joy as
far as we know because there's no way of
checking it is the largest collection of
British mail balls overall in the UK but
I do have friends who specialized it
ties up well with holidays trips abroad
we go to places where you wouldn't
imagine people would go even Trappist
monks from hong kong had their own milk
in bottles somebody rings me up or I get
a tip on there's a dairy closing down or
somebody's found a barn with some milk
bottles I'm away I like the glass and I
like the social history they're nice to
handle milk bottles do have a sort of
tactile feel to them this one is has got
Union Jack on and this is just a very
nice example where you have the blue and
the red and obviously the milk when it's
inside provides the white background
well I've always net not really just
don't like milk um nothing I would ever
drink I was believe it's it's into the
baby food and ever since they brought
out what I call blue milk was that milk
or no fat in it
have you ever had cornflakes with
skimmed milk it's awful topics we talk
about when domain get together coarser
Airport luggage carousels we started
making notes whether they go clockwise
or counterclockwise we don't like the
word so much anti-clockwise it infers
that we're against clocks we like clocks
we particularly like clocks twice a year
when we get to stay up late and change
it to in the morning but anyway the
predominant way is counterclockwise not
clockwise and you engineer from Gatwick
Airport explained to us why is because
most people are right-handed and you've
got better leverage to pick up your bag
off the rack if it's coming from your
left and clockwise from your right
it all started back in around about 1999
I worked for for 16 years at Rothwell
Kohler II just south of Leeds all the
buildings have been demolished it was a
derelict site the reason I got into
brick collecting was because I noticed
that these bricks were lying about and
the names of the brick makers were there
and that's where the interest started
because none of these brick makers were
still in business I thought really that
it was part of our industrial heritage
that's gone by the board so anyway when
I got them home by this time I picked up
maybe about 40 different bricks with
defeat makers names up didn't know what
to do with them so I eventually finished
up putting a path down and building a
small wall here with the name showing
and it became a bit of an obsession so
every time we go out now nine times out
of ten I will come back with a brick and
it would add to the collection anyhow
draw you'd be surprised where they are
but all over the place and nobody wants
them except us
[Music]
my wife Maureen is a wee bit
long-suffering over the brick problem
because I put maybe three rows of bricks
down here and as I got more and more at
to extend it but I'll take in upper
glass so then out to go to the wall and
build the wall up a wee bit but that
keeps falling down it was a battleground
yeah but
one eventually but I didn't put any more
down there the lines definitely drawn my
wife of 41 or 42 years is a very very
supportive of what what I do she uh is a
bit more minimalist if you like than me
she often comes with me while we're
watching and looking for post boxes she
helps me once every year or so where we
clean everybody bottle in there this is
dull it is not all post boxes but I am
let off the leash every now and again
and she's quite happy for me to go
wandering my ex-wife hated the fact that
I was a roundabouts button in the end
she left me but I don't mind her because
I can go out there round about spotting
whenever I run I love riding escalators
[Music]
a long write is enjoyable you can stand
there and relax and not be anxious about
getting off for a while just stand back
there and look at the pictures on each
side the adverts and the longer ride the
adverts repeats themselves every so
often so if you miss completely reading
one at one point you can just wait to
get a little farther down the escalator
and it'll appear again I quite frankly
don't know why people walk on those
escalators and if you're going to walk
take the stairs
leave the escalators alone for us people
to just enjoy a pure escalator right I
just marvel at engineering behind
escalators to think that they're doing
the job for us that I don't have to
exert myself to go down stairs or go
back upstairs
it's like I'm just floating down into
the subway station
[Music]
somebody or say our doll I take it as a
compliment actually you can call me doll
if you like I thought there's no such
thing as an uninteresting roundabout
even the humble TNT stroke of genius
equal but we don't like driving over
those things you should navigate
accordingly and go round and if it does
look artistic suppose it does really fun
Dick Tracy hemming could make something
out of them do you think alright mate
this is one of the fellow roundabouts
Potter's here he's actually make love on
a round a babe haven't you hmm
he's a what we call a bonking Bowser you
know life seems to be continually
speeding up cars are faster planes are
faster now the modern world is busy busy
busy
the thing that illustrates it mortem to
us is the mobile form to date I don't
have a mobile phone
the can play music but can the can do
everything with a simple mobile
performance about half the size of a
brick don't need one I don't walk into
telegraph poles I like to take in as
much of where I'm going on what's in
front of me as I can it can take time
and reflect on life could be an old
lamppost a finger-posts or directional
sign we need to just take a step back
and just go round around about twice
slowly there's a lot to be said for
being dull everything is you're made of
last longer it used to get us out
dancing you've got you the exercise if
you suffer from a nervous disposition or
heart trouble
it's the perfect hobby for you is just
to sit back and take in these beautiful
pieces of round architecture people
often ask is is this dull men's club is
it a move
no it's not a movement we like to stay
put people also ask us is a domains club
one of these 12-step programs no 12-step
programs try to get people to change
your behavior the domains club is a
two-step program we admit we're dull and
we're going to keep it that way
[Music]
I'm Natasha guy likes the syusai I'm
always in one place and that's my front
room and when I find myself
not enough of it I get myself to bed
such a sensible thing to do I'm not the
one to run
I don't like wandering
yes on the water Oh No
right now
you
[Music]
Oh
[Music]